what would it be like to travel to Mars
and be one of its first colonists well
to get a small taste National Geographic
is sponsoring this video and sending me
on a microgravity experience a vomit
comet come on this plane flies in a
series of parabolic arcs so that if and
everything inside can essentially be in
freefall
creating a microgravity environment the
plane can also simulate the gravity on
other bodies like the Moon and Mars by
modifying the parabola if I were really
going to Mars I would experience not 30
seconds of microgravity as I do in this
plane but eight months of it and then
when I got to Mars this would be the
gravity on the surface this is what it
would be like to be on the surface of
Mars
there the gravity is only about 37% of
what it is on earth which means you'd be
able to jump much higher if you're an
average jumper on earth you get double
the airtime on Mars and have no problem
at all dunking on a regulation
basketball hoop
[Music]
the moon the gravity is only 1/6 of what
it is here on earth so you could really
do a lot of crazy aerobics without being
exhausted one major issue with low
gravity is that it's not very easy to
exercise I mean you're used to the fact
that your arm weighs about 5% of your
body weight so just lifting your arm and
regular G is a little bit of a workout
you don't get any of that when you are
traveling to Mars and you only get a
fraction of it when you're actually on
Mars on a journey to Mars as on the
space station your muscles would weaken
and shrink they would atrophy studies
have shown that muscle mass can decrease
by up to 20%
on space flights lasting just 5 to 11
days so you'd have to exercise lifting
weights would be useless so you'd have
to rely on elastic resistance for
example on the space station astronauts
are elastically tethered to a treadmill
and they typically exercise two and a
half hours everyday even so the lack of
weight pushing on bones results in a
decrease in bone density astronauts can
lose one to two percent of bone mass per
month mostly in their lower extremities
that's over 10 times faster bone loss
than people on earth experience through
osteoporosis as they get older and in
weightless conditions other forces
become significant like the surface
tension of water everyday activities
become a lot more challenging even
things like washing your face Oh
probably gonna hat
that is crazy look at the surface
tension the water holds it together like
that dealing with liquids and
microgravity is really difficult
which makes showering brushing your
teeth and going to the bathroom
much harder it's one of the most
challenging things
[Music]
I got just gonna up my nose
[Music]
[Music]
got it in the absence of Earth's gravity
you would also notice some strange
effects like what happens when I spin
this I showed how on earth this disc
flips Heaviside up when you spin it so I
wanted to see what happens in
microgravity right here do you see it
flipping back and forth did you see that
let me slow it down so you can see it
better the disc actually flips back and
forth the hole goes from one side to the
other and back watch which side of the
disc the hole is on first its facing
towards me and then it flips away from
me and now it's towards me again and now
it's away from me this effect has
actually been seen on the space station
with a t-bar handle it's an example of
the intermediate axis theorem that is
rotation about an intermediate axis not
the least or a greatest moment of
inertia is unstable and any tiny
disturbance will cause it to rotate
about another axis as well in addition
to dealing with microgravity on a trip
to Mars you would also be exposed to
significant amounts of radiation when
it's bedtime on orbit normally you fall
asleep pretty quickly because because
you're tired but once in a while you
have your eyes closed and you're not
asleep yet and you occasionally will see
a flash of light it's some sort of human
body reaction to the radiation from the
universe and we think it is heavy
particles or individual bursts of energy
coming from radiation that are either
going through the eyeball itself or
going through the optic nerve a picture
back to the first astronauts who must
have closed their eyes and seen that
radiation and going I'm not going to
tell anybody about this because no one's
told me about I'm not talking I can just
imagine the first two guys that said hey
I am sometimes I see flashes of light do
you see flashes of light and then oh we
all see flashes alike oh okay well
that's that's alright then to me all of
these difficulties represent not deal
breakers but challenges to be overcome
for humans to guarantee our long-term
survival we
must become a multiplanetary species on
mars simply stepping into a spacesuit
which currently weigh as much as 310
pounds would make you feel about as
heavy as you are on earth so maybe you
wouldn't feel like a basketball star
after all but this would also allow you
to maintain your muscle and bone mass
it's not that hard to shield yourself
for radiation you can put it into the
insulation of the ship you can use water
of course it's a terrific radiation
absorber so you can shield the ship but
you can't ignore it and of course one of
the major challenges of different
gravity is the nausea that it brings our
bodies are not necessarily evolved to be
these different gravity situations so
we've just gone through 50 parabolas I
don't know if I could last many more
before I start to lose my breakfast you
know what I'm saying but you know our
bodies evolved for millions of years in
9.8 m/s^2 gravity if we ever moved to
Mars then actually established qualities
and live there our evolution may take us
in very different directions thanks to
the National Geographic Channel for
sending me on this zero-g adventure it's
truly awesome life on Mars may be closer
than you think
check out national Geographics new
season of Mars on Monday November 12th
at 9/8 central